so like before v tubing you said you
were into cosplaying so how did you get
into that
oh it's a long story
time love um um do you know a visual k
bands yeah yeah of course yes yeah and i
was a fan of visual cave bands and
that's where i started cosplaying my
first cosplay was a visual k band
cosplay what was the band what bands
were you into um the band um i don't
think you guys know it but it's called
gazette oh yeah gazette yeah you guys
know it i don't know the gazette you
don't know i'm not going to pretend i do
i'm sorry
i used to cosplay as a member of that
and other visual key visual key bands
that's where i started
like nightmare and like oh yeah
gilgamesh and all those guys oh you know
gilgamesh i love gilgamesh oh
yeah yeah
as
yeah
that makes a lot of sense actually
because yeah that is started from there
it wasn't from anime everyone thinks
it's from anime but it wasn't
i was banned from anime
i was banned from manchester united
aloud though
um
i
don't think so but my
my parents didn't know anything about it
so they weren't able to ban it from me
because a lot of a lot of visual cave
bands are pretty like raunchy yeah i
know i know yeah like you listen to like
duron gray it's like oh my god i don't
want my kids listening to that
jesus christ
so did you start off making your own
cosplays or did you buy your cosplays at
first and then you kind of learnt it
along the way i was making it because my
mommy my mommy is really good at sewing
she teach me how to show
when i was little and i was kind of
into sewing so i started i was really
interested in the costumes right the
visual k bands costumes are really
really cool
yeah you guys know it it's really yeah
it's insane cool it's insane so i really
i was like i saw it as art
and i really wanted to make it make one
so i started it and then i end up being
an anime girl
no i
did you do like the visual makeup as
well yeah yeah yeah i used to i used to
have no eyebrows
wait why
so you draw it on
oh yeah they don't have it oh
most visual key page okay people don't
have eyebrows
i did a video with a visual k band and i
don't remember
if they had
eyebrows i'm trying to remember if they
had eyebrows
i mean i mean it's not like it's not
like a requirement
you made it sound like it was a thing
where it's a greeting it's like oh you
want to be a visual caveman give it to
my brother get rid of the eyebrows
funny image of like visual k bands with
like the eyebrows photoshopped out have
you seen someone without eyebrows it
looks really weird it looks super yeah
scary i would know because i i had to
like shave my eyebrows off uh because
when i went became a monk yeah and that
looked like 10 times weirder than me
having a bold head right the bold head
meant nothing because all i could see
was just like my eyebrow less [ __ ]
face yeah it was it's super [ __ ]
weird i can't describe wait did you have
the shaved head with no eyebrows yeah
no hair
double whammy she's just like [ __ ] mr
potato head or something no even here
even he has [ __ ] eyebrows
it's just like his eyes and her mouth
that's what it looked like
it looks so weird so i've noticed in
some of your streams you've done a lot
of meme reviews oh yeah
yeah so
what that's good what nothing i'm
smiling
connor's smiling what is that
yeah so i wanted to ask like how what's
your opinion between like japanese memes
versus western memes right because i've
only like i only get like a glimpse of
japanese memes every now and again so i
don't really know what kind of memes are
even hot or popular what like the sense
of humor is what is what is your opinion
on that well i only review like um
western memes so i i don't know much
about japanese memes but i've seen some
and i only reviewed uh those
western memes i because i
understand the jokes right right
are you trying to say you don't
understand what to say
western memes are better
that's kind of what i wanted
to be
better honest
not something don't like drip goku
i i mean to be honest i prefer the
western memes over the japanese memes
yeah japanese memes it's it's so weird
it's so weird and complicated for me
sometimes i really don't understand why
they're doing it like like i i feel the
baseline japanese meme is like the same
level as a multi-layered western meme
where it's where it's like you have to
it's like it's like reference over
reference over reference to like fully
understand they have anything like uh-oh
stinky in in japanese i don't think so
you know uh-oh stinky i don't know that
[Music]
stinky it's a really dumb meme
next time you do a meme review yeah
okay this is one of those clips right
bear in mind this is like one where you
hear it first time you're like this is i
don't like this and then you hear it
five times you're like why is this so
funny
all right so me and joey going to talk
while
connor phone
stinky
puppies
what am i watching
the pinnacle of western memes cases when
you're trying to explain my job to my
mom
she just walks up to a dinosaur and goes
oh sneaky
no japanese memes are not like that
i don't know why we have that kind of
humor in the way well that's some of
them but there are a bunch of other ones
as well yeah how do you like our memes
very fond of them yeah sometimes i like
anti-memes as well and i like
sometimes
i don't i don't know it's i can't even
get my own humor a lot of the time and
sometimes meme just don't make sense
what just i don't know
it is true because it's like the more
memes i've seen from both the japanese
and english side the more i don't know
what's funny anymore
i don't know what's humor anymore yeah
yeah
i can watch a a
stand-up comedy thing like yeah that's
comedy yeah and then i go to memes i'm
like is this
i'm laughing like is this funny or is it
entertaining i don't know can you guys
describe a japanese meme that you found
for me
you know the one that everyone always
sung praises of japanese vine everyone
always said that was really good
i thought japanese japanese vine is
really good yeah and like and like a lot
of japanese tick tocks as well like
minus the ones where it's just like hot
girls dancing like the ones where it's
like actually you know divine energy
coming back onto tick-tock like some of
those are pretty funny but it's like i
don't know i feel a lot like japanese
memes a lot more like very surreal where
it's like it's more like what the [ __ ]
is this more so than this is funny
kind of thing would you say that yeah
yeah yeah yeah well you look at it it's
like oh this is really weird but also
kind of entertaining but you don't
necessarily like laugh at it yeah you
know
you guys uh do you know the uh the
japanese guy like standing in seizing oh
yeah thank you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know that one yeah it's not funny
right
it's is that a fun that's not a funny
thing that's
great i love it but that's a meme that's
a japanese japanese me i mean that's an
inspiring meme
i'm like i'm like good good for you guys
i get behind that yeah but that's the
thing it's like i feel in japan memes
are used more as a creative outlet right
like as in like people take a meme that
is not necessarily funny but they
recreate it in different like artistic
ways to like kind of be like look what i
can do with this one thing that everyone
knows kind of thing whereas in the west
you get uh-oh stinky
sauce
and sauce where it's like it's funny
is it creative
though
i'm not too sure like you know
there are a few words where that meme
has just ruined yeah for me like a monk
is one of them
i can't hear them anymore
i love memes because they they almost
paint a picture of the current time like
yeah accurately you can really get a
sense of the feel for the time with with
a meme yeah i think
memes are almost like a language yeah
they are there
because i'm the cv yeah memes yeah you
know what in [ __ ] 100 years maybe
memes will become a language in itself
because you know sometimes you see a
meme and you don't understand it at all
but sometimes you see a meme and there
are so many layers that are being
conveyed in this one meme that you just
get instantly right but then the problem
is with the explaining memes like that
people who don't get it is that you look
like a [ __ ] idiot when you have to
yeah they're like why are you telling me
that you find all of these things
individually funny and then when it's
combined you also find it even funnier
like what's wrong with you okay okay but
have you ever had a meme where you've
never heard of it before right someone
shows it to you you're just like what
the [ __ ] is this and he they explain why
it's funny and you're just like that's
not funny every time i just i just saw
it
every time every every meme then i think
it's dominant
but then eventually you see it a second
time like oh that's that's kind of
amusing like you see the third time so
you give yourself a little chuckle um
come like the hundredth time you see
that meme and you're like [ __ ]
pissing yourself at one note in that
meme or something like that you know
that's that's like that's like memes to
me nowadays yeah yeah especially when
you're wearing where it gets to the
point where you just have to listen to
one millisecond or like you start
laughing right now i've asked a lot of
people this what's your favorite meme my
favorite meme yeah did you get off the
top of your head what came to your head
came to my uh they they invention meme
do you guys know that invention
invention i don't know this one like
something was invented in 19 blah blah
blah
but before that boom
do you know that
you guys
what about that meme do you like so much
oh oh oh
like this one oh i get it i get it yeah
like the depression was invented in 1856
people before depression
it's just like a smiling dude
this is pretty damn funny
you know that's that's that's the best
memes right the worst memes are the ones
where you see on twitter one day we see
you on tick tock and it lasts literally
a day i've seen memes just last a day
and
can you even call the memes at that
point no like it's just a funny image
like that's all it is
it's just some dude posted a funny image
and a lot of people liked it that's i
guess i guess that's what a meme isn't
yeah
i guess that is i guess that's what
congratulations joey i figured out what
a meme is that's
for the longest time i thought it was
maybe
when like when like troll comics were
first the thing
is it it's melee right
what melee like when you hit someone
like super smash brothers yeah yeah it's
melee when i was a kid i just like could
not ellie i like melly yeah
i called him milly when i was a kid yeah
m-e-l-e-e yeah
because when you say m-e-l-e-e like
melee
that's another one of those words where
i remember to sympathy as a child i just
did not know which one it was and i
would kind of be like super smash
brother minnie
wait so is it mellie or melee i say
melee melee no wait what do i say i
forgot what i said melee melee melee
melee
okay
i'm i'm getting like a [ __ ]
um what's what's that moment called
where
your memory is different than what oh
the uh mandela effect yeah i'm getting a
mandela effect right now i think because
i swear when you booted up the game the
announcer pronounced it mainly
no no he didn't he definitely did it he
goes like super smash brothers melee
it wasn't an american accent i swear to
god it was but the guy doing it is an
american yeah i'm sure it's an american
yeah it's xander right
who does it he's the one who does the
main voice of the he does joker himself
yeah
he he did that yeah he's the same guy
he's been voice lighting for that long
yeah yeah holy [ __ ] he's the announcer
for smash
i did not know that and i'm pretty sure
he says melee i think right does he does
he i think
mine's just blind i know nothing about
mario
when you play
i don't know anything about pokemon i
know nothing about marriott
says along with usually says a lot about
society there's a lot about something
yeah when you play a game
i'll let them finish
i'll let them finish a little bit when
you play a game english or japanese are
you picking which one you going for
um the first one that popped out
the first one that popped out yeah if it
popped
[Music]
it literally doesn't matter it doesn't
matter for me oh wow
i guess because you can play both right
yeah yeah oh my god i guess it's kind of
the same with me as well like if the
original
is japanese if it's an originally a
japanese game i'll play it in japanese
unless i have to stream it but if it's
made from a western studio then i'll
play it it's like swiss people with
european versions they're like oh which
language i speak all of them it doesn't
matter
[ __ ] off
[ __ ] off yeah um yeah